>>> THE DEMOCRATIC REPUBLIC OF
CONGO IS ON HIGH ALERT FOR THE
THREAT OF ANOTHER VOLCANIC
ERUPTION.
YOU CAN SEE ASH RISING FROM THE
CRATER HERE.
A LOCAL OFFICIAL SAID 92
EARTHQUAKES WERE RECORDED WITHIN
A 24-HOUR PERIOD.
A DEADLY ERUPTION OCCURRED MORE
THAN A WEEK AGO WITH THE LAVA
FLOW SWALLOWING UP HOMES, ROADS,
EVERYTHING IN ITS PATH.
THE DEPUTY HEAD OF THE U.N.
PEACEKEEPING FORCE IN CONGO SAYS
MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS IS
NEEDED TO REPAIR THE DAMAGE.
WE'RE SEEING SOME OF THE
DESTRUCTION AND I KNOW YOU TOOK
TO THE AIR TO SEE THE VOLCANO'S
CRATER FOR YOURSELF.
THE SHOT BEHIND YOU IS PRETTY
DEVASTATING.
WHAT DID YOU SEE WHEN YOU GOT
ABOVE?
>> WE SAW THE GENESIS OF THE
LAVA AND PEOPLE'S HOMES UNDER
THE FIELD OF LAVA.
FROM THE SKY WE SAW WHERE THE
RED HOT LAVA FLOWED FROM
ESSENTIALLY.
IT'S BEEN REPLACED NOW BY GRAY
ASHES.
THAT, EXPERTS TELL US, IS
PROBABLY A GOOD SIGN AND MEANS
THE CRATER IS COLLAPSING AND
THERE IS NOTHING UNDER THERE SO
THERE IS NO IMMINENT DANGER.
HOWEVER, EXPERTS FROM THE
VOLCANIC OBSERVATORY DID TWO
FLYOVERS TODAY AND DID PICK UP
SOME FISSURES, SOME LITTLE HOLES
HERE AND THERE THAT APPEAR TO BE
THE BEGINNING OF SOMETHING.
THERE IS NOT A LOT TO MAKE OF
THAT AT THIS POINT BUT WHAT
THEY'RE TELLING PEOPLE IS TO BE
VIGILANT.
THEY'RE NOT RULING OUT THE
POSSIBILITY THERE COULD BE A
GROUND ERUPTION OR WATER
ERUPTION.
ONE OF THE PEOPLE WE FLEW WITH
YESTERDAY HAS BEEN STUDYING THIS
MOUNTAIN SINCE 1995 AND
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO
HIM TO SAY IS THIS ALL OVER?
THIS IS HIS RESPONSE.
>> NOT RULING OUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF ANOTHER ERUPTION
I AM THINKING AND SAYING THAT
STATISTICALLY THERE ARE VERY FEW
CHANCES THIS CAN HAPPEN.
>> Reporter: WHAP THAT MEANS IS
THAT THE DANGER APPEARS TO BE --
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF BEING
DISPLACED AND WANT TO COME BACK
HOME BUT WE CAN'T ASSURE YOU IF
YOU COME BACK HOME.
THE GROUND OR WATER MIGHT
EXPLODE.
>> THE DEPUTY HEAD OF THE U.N.
PEACEKEEPING ESTIMATING, LARRY,
THAT TO DATE DAMAGE WILL COST
MORE THAN A BILLION DOLLARS TO
REPAIR, TALKING ABOUT ROADS,
WATER, ELECTRICITY SUPPLY, AND
FOR A LITTLE CONTEXT FOR OUR
VIEWERS SOMETHING LIKE THE
EQUIVALENT OF 2% OF THE
COUNTRY'S GDP.
I MEAN, HOW ARE THOSE REBUILDING
EFFORTS LIKELY TO PLAY OUT AT
THIS POINT?
HOW ARE PEOPLE GOING TO COPE IN
THE NEAR TO MEDIUM TERM?
>> Reggie: THE IMMEDIATE CONCERN
IS PRESERVING LIFE.
>> Reporter: THE IMMEDIATE
CONCERN IS PRESERVING LIFE
KEEPING PEOPLE AWAY FROM ANOTHER
ERUPTION IF IT HAPPENS.
HUMANITARIAN AGENCIES ARE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THEY HAVE FOOD AND
MEDICINES AND NO OUTBREAK OF
COVID-19 OR CHOLERA WHICH HAS
BROKEN OUT IN THE PAST HERE.
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE HOMES.
THE WOMAN WHO LIVED NEXT DOOR,
HER HOME IS UNDER THIS.
HOW DOES SHE EVEN START?
SHE DIDN'T HAVE INSURANCE.
SHE MIGHT NOT GET ANY GOVERNMENT
SUPPORT.
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER STORIES
LIKE THAT.
900 HOMES WERE COMPLETELY
FLATTENED.
80,000 HOUSEHOLDS HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED BY THIS.
ANOTHER ERUPTION COULD BE
CATASTROPHIC.
THE U.N. PEACEKEEPING MISSION
HERE HAS TOLD US THEY WILL NEED
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS TO TRY
AND REPAIR WHAT'S LEFT IN THIS
PART OF THE EASTERN DRC.
THAT IS SEVERAL YEARS AWAY,
HOPING THERE IS NO OTHER
ERUPTION IN